[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i'm going to be covering
something topical related to harry
potter that's not something i can say
very often this video will of course be
discussing the upcoming fantastic beasts
film fantastic beasts 3 however
fortunately we don't have to just call
it fantastic beasts 3 anymore that's
because warner bros announced the title
of the film just two short days ago
revealing it to be fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore this title follows
the first installment in the series
fantastic beasts and where to find them
as well as the second installment
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald this video is going to cover
some of the information that we have on
the film so far as well as answer some
lingering questions that fans might have
about the upcoming films including
questions about the plot characters and
release date i'm going to be repeating a
few pieces of information from the last
video because i want this to be
comprehensive but a lot of it's new
let's get into it is there a trailer
available for fantastic beasts 3
apparently filming for the upcoming
fantastic beasts film is over but with
that said no official footage of the
film has been released as of yet the
crimes of grindelwald got a trailer
eight months in advance of its release
and were now seven months away from the
release of this film so i certainly
expect to see one soon release date the
film was originally scheduled for
november 2020
but was postponed due to the need for a
screenplay rewrite this pushed the film
back to november 2021 but then disaster
struck in the form of a pandemic and the
film was postponed again the new release
date being july 2022 being pushed back
even further with all of that said
however you might be glad to hear that
fantastic beast 3 is now actually ahead
of schedule and will be released during
easter 2022 april 15th to be exact how
many films will there be now when the
fantastic beasts films were first
announced we were told that we were
going to be given five films in total
however after the second film failed to
perform at the level that they had
expected there were rumors that the
fantastic beast films can instead be
concluded in a trilogy ending after only
the third installment instead however
these are just rumors and warner bros
haven't released any definitive
statements regarding how many films we
can expect to receive with that said
however i still think there are going to
be five films we've been given two films
so far which means that based on a
five-part film series we're forty
percent of the way in the total time
scale of the fantastic beast story is 18
years but from the first two films we've
only been given two of those years 1926
and 1927. given that we've still got so
many years to cover i really don't see
how it could be wrapped up so suddenly
we've only really just scratched the
surface of the plots and characters so
all i know is that i'd be bitterly
disappointed if it wrapped up in three
we can definitely expect a time jump
from the third film but to jump all the
way to the end in 1945 would be
surprising characters we could possibly
see one rumor which has yet to be
confirmed suggests that maybe just maybe
we will see hagrid and young tom riddle
in the upcoming fantastic beasts film
this is something that i have always
hoped for suspected i think it may be
true for a number of reasons it makes
sense from a timeline perspective
the crimes of grindelwald takes place in
the year 1927 and grindelwald is still
very much on his rise to power the film
closes in this same year and grindelwald
still has so much character development
to undergo as does everyone else tom
riddle starts at hogwarts in the year
1938 and hagrid starts in the year 1940.
as grindelwald isn't actually defeated
until the year 1945 it would make total
sense that these two characters would
make an appearance eddie redmayne aka
newt scamander has expressed himself in
reddit ama that he'd like to see hagrid
return he was asked the question which
character would you like to see star in
fantastic beasts 3 to which redmayne
replied with an enthusiastic hagrid
hagrid always hagrid given that redmayne
is such an important part of the
fantastic beasts films it really does at
least in my eyes give me a glimmer of
hope that perhaps hagrid and maybe even
tom riddle will return bearing all that
information in mind we also need to
remember the timeline of the films which
end as late as 1945. this gives us quite
a large window of possibility and to
have them not appear at all would be an
injustice with that time frame in mind
we can also speculate as to which other
characters we may see make an appearance
moaning myrtle immediately comes to mind
as she is the same age as hagrid and
famously suffered at the hands of the
basilisk in the chamber of secrets
professor horace slughorn also comes to
mind as he was a professor at hogwarts
during this time and famously taught tom
riddle if tom riddle is to make an
appearance i also suspect that we will
see the members of his gang who would
later become death eaters we know that
one of voldemort's gang members is named
lestrange and i'm sure you guys can
think of a few other characters that
share the same last name perhaps this is
the father of rodolfos i'm really
excited to see how things unfold and
which characters they bring on board the
new title the new title of the film
replacing fantastic beasts 3 is
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore a fitting title given the
cliffhanger that we were left on after
the second installment i'll get more
into that in the next question is
credence a dumbledore at the end of the
crimes of grindelwald a rather major
plot point is revealed to us credence
barebone the powerful obscurial is
dumbledore's long lost brother aurelius
if true and credence is in fact a
dumbledore it is huge news because it
adds a major character to harry potter
canon in rita skeeters the life and lies
of albus dumbledore it's made very clear
that there's a lot about the dumbledore
family the public doesn't know so it's
very possible they're related though
grindelwald doesn't confirm who exactly
aurelius parents are since he refers to
albus as the young man's brother we can
safely assume that he belongs to at
least one of albus's parents
albus was the eldest son in the
dumbledore family and his parents were
percival and kendra dumbledore before
this point in time it was widely thought
that there were only three dumbledore
children albus aberforth and ariana but
if aurelius is a dumbledore it's
unlikely he's the son of both kendra and
percival percival was in azkaban from
1890 onward and there's no way that they
could have conceived a child there
however there is always the possibility
that kendra had a child with another man
while percival was imprisoned this child
regardless of the father would be
albus's half-brother if she gave birth
in 1898 a year before she died then
credence would be 27 28 in the films
kendra's shame might also explain why
baby aurelius was on a ship bound for
america plot accompanying the new title
and release we've also been given some
tidbits about the plot of the upcoming
film in the form of synopsis professor
albus dumbledore knows the powerful dark
wizard grindelwald is moving to seize
control of the wizarding world it reads
unable to stop him alone he entrusts
mata's zoologist newt scamander to lead
an intrepid team of wizards witches and
one brave muggle baker on a dangerous
mission where they encounter old and new
beasts and clash with grindelwald's
growing legion of followers but with the
stake so high how long can dumbledore
remain on the sidelines dan fogler who
plays jacob also said the following
about the film in an interview last year
the character development is really
lovely it's very similar to the feel of
the first movie which i think is great
he said it's leading toward this massive
war with the backdrop of world war ii so
you can just imagine epic battle scenes
are coming fogler's co-star catherine
waterston who plays tina goldstein said
the following i never really know what
i'm supposed to say or not say she
explained but yes i can confirm there
will be surprises i just thought of one
in fact it surprised me i think that's
about as far as i can go i don't know
about you guys but i'm excited that's it
for today's video until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you